[Musique]
au cœur du premier arrondissement de
Paris la Comédie Française cette
institution incontournable du théâtre
français célèbre ce matin une classe de
jeunes collégiens réunionnaise
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
retour quelques semaines en arrière une
petite troupe fait résonner les
répliques de Molière dans la cour du
collège rockfeuille de Saint-Paul
est un certain animal difficile à
connaître
il faut l'avouer l'amour est un bien
grand maître ce qu'on n'en plus jamais
il nous enseigna lettre le collège
Roquefeuille inauguré par le département
de La Réunion en 2021 et l'un des
derniers collèges construit sur l'île il
a accueilli misanthrope femme savante et
autres maladies imaginaires sur le thème
de l'amour
retour à Paris grâce à l'aide du
département et des collectivités la
joyeuse troupe a pu aller jusqu’à la
capitale pour recevoir un prix anne-sol
Wayon professeur de français à l'origine
de l'initiative nous explique la genèse
de ce projet mais le soir
on a participé à un concours le concours
d'hommage à Molière pour les 350 ans de
sa mort on a découvert ça au mois de
décembre et on a souhaité y participer
le théâtre c'est vraiment un acteur de
l'école qui nous permet si vous voulez
de développer des compétences qu'on est
censé acquérir en fin de collège pour
nous
l'accès à une culture de qualité qui est
trop souvent réservée à un public aisé
et à un public dit intellectuel je pense
qu'il est très important de désacraliser
le théâtre pour de s'autoriser à aller
au théâtre et dans ce genre de théâtre
au total dans toute la France 200
classes se sont inscrites au concours du
dispositif à vous de jouer de la Comédie
Française la troupe de jeunes
Réunionnais a reçu le prix de la
catégorie collège avec la chance de
visiter cet institution et d'y recevoir
leur diplôme quelle fierté de voir des
jeunes collégiens de
se lancer dans les subtilités de la
langue de Molière
j'ai pu voir donc cette vidéo qui a été
transmise au jury national où on voyait
des jeunes talents récités des vers et
des phrases des comédies du Grand la
grande ramature
je français de la Comédie-Française et
bien le département encourage cette ce
genre d'initiative et on espère voir
d'autres collégiens dans ce même élan la
Comédie Française est heureuse de vous
décerner le premier prix du jury du jeu
concours les jeunes rendent hommage à
Molière à Paris les 8 juin 2023
un diplôme un poster un buste de Molière
et une aventure inoubliable dans les
meilleurs critiques sont bien sûr les
enfants
[Musique]
c'est vraiment la Comédie Française
là-bas il y a plein de spectacles il y a
des trucs hyper connus et du coup bah le
fait que toi toi là que tu il y a même
pas deux trois semaines tu étais en
train de faire tes devoirs dans ta
chambre tu te retrouves à recevoir un
prix la Comédie Française a gagné un
concours donc c'est incroyable c'est
quelque chose qui va se réaliser une
fois dans ta vie qu'on voit le théâtre
il y a le rideau et les acteurs qui
jouent là on avait vraiment tout en
profondeur et c'était vachement géant
c'est incroyable parce que en plus on a
gagné ça à la salle Richelieu à la
Comédie Française donc bah c'est c'est
énorme l'endroit on a organisé un voyage
à Paris en quelques semaines seulement
tu m'amuse et puis je découvre et je
trouve ça l'histoire du théâtre je
trouve ça magnifique en fait une façon
de s'exprimer
différentes des autres on a tous été
réunis alors qu'on se serait peut-être
pas réunis
parce qu'on aimait le théâtre jouer des
rôles et du coup ben on adore tous se
retrouver et faire qu'on aime donc le
théâtre ça m'a beaucoup donné envie
d'être comédienne franchement parce que
quand on regarde les émotions
retranscrites par les comédiens leur
travail qui peuvent des fois être fait
en très peu de temps
préparer une pièce c'est pas facile
parce que nous d'ailleurs on fait et
franchement ben c'est incroyable c'est
magique les 15 élèves sont sont des
graines de comédiens puisque ils ont été
sélectionnés par des professionnels
voilà alors ils apprennent ils sont au
tout début de leur formation mais on a
tous senti qu'il y avait quelque chose
qui allait éclore et voilà c'est pour ça
qu'ils sont là
ça a donné envie d'être comédienne là
cette journée
[Musique]